speaking of the future adam how do you
feel about uh
caitlyn jenner running for governor oh
can't get worse than newsome
right no i'm i'm like somebody said to
me
i actually went down to uh tinhorn flats
in burbank do you know about that do you
know about tin
that that restaurant no oh god oh it's
so fun
you'd go nuts nuts i don't want to say
you tell your story and then i'll tell
you once we tell you about tin horn
flats then that's an excuse to kill
yourself
i don't think we should do it i don't
know if we want to go down there the
future's bright
wait do you hear this this will piss you
off all right so
uh so i went to school with the
lepagians
who are in our armenian family and
they ran this this tavern in burbank
like
one of the oldest bars in in burbank it
was kind of a honky-tonky
kind of fun place to hang out in and
so then all the coveted restrictions
came in and burbank is
super militant nazis over there they're
over regulating
anyway so they close everything down so
they have a big
outdoor dining area and
so they move everyone outdoors and
they're doing all the regulations and
all the
you know all the hoops everyone's got to
jump through but then at some point
as you recall they shut down outdoor
dining
and tin horn flats is like f this
there's no science there's no data to
support
shutting down outdoor there is no
outdoor anything as far as covet goes
beaches
playgrounds parks you know outdoor
dining
just huge overreach by the government so
they go
you can actually see me on tmz with my
son
walking into tin horn flats not on the
internet close your eyes
but i want you to imagine not on the
internet let me shoot everybody
so so they so tinhorn flats goes
we're going to we're going to leave our
outdoor dining open not indoor
but outdoor of course city of burbank
gets involved
and by the way if you guys remember the
outdoor dining thing was shut down for
three or four weeks and then they
reopened it because there was no
data to support it i have a friend who
works on the cdc board
and they in this kid goes i'm sorry why
are we shutting down outdoor dining and
their exact
uh that's the wrong reasoning they said
optics
right so so now so tin horn flats
defies them uh mark garrigus takes the
case um
they go in front of the judge and the
judge basically tells the city you got
to produce
some evidence that outdoor dining is
dangerous
otherwise you know i'm going to throw
this out they produce
no evidence and they shut them down
they put first they first they blocked
the door they padlocked the door
and tin horn flats like cuts off the
padlock
then they sandbagged the door and like
plywood the door tin horn flats
moves things now they put a huge
they put a huge fence around it and
completely shut it down like
i went by there like literally cemented
into the ground
wow so really that was uh me and my son
so
during the protest because i went to
high school with the guy and generally
don't like this crazy government
overreach i'm like i'll take my son
and we'll go eat a tin horn flat so tmz
caught us
walking in essentially to tin horn flat
so so we did this already going on i
mean i saw the tweets all be blunt you
know you're like [ __ ] knew something are
you [ __ ] knew something
so is this about is this primarily about
what's happening to
to the small businesses to the
restaurants here or
i guess i want to be on this place so
we thought we'd do that but listen i
don't know who newsom thinks he is
he's not a monarch no you can't shut
down society you gotta offer some proof
why it's dangerous
and by the way sheep wake up sheep i'm
scared
it's not newsom it's all the sheep that
just listen to newsome
i get it so so uh we should have never
listened
he doesn't have a point capacity i mean
how does that factor into allowing
you know these businesses to be open do
you think that's the problem do you
think that
dining out can reflect is this
contributing to
not outdoor dining not outdoor dining
well not
i'm not seeing any studies right so
there's no data
okay so we're gonna go outdoor dining
okay and and i want you to enjoy your
meal i don't want to keep you too long
on
this new some recall thing what do you
think about that it's terrible
it'd be nice yeah yeah do you think
it'll it'll gain
some ground i think it is gaining some
ground because he's an
imbecile and he's incompetent he's
running this state into the ground so
hopefully
we can uh listen we should recall him
and just replace him with one of those
plastic owls they put on
that's so good well we better because i
i've said you can you can stop
i i've said like anyone who's ever
worked in radio
you'd rather have no program director
than a bad program director
you'd rather have like no coach than a
bad coach yes you know if you really
think about
life like i'd rather have no governor
yep than a horrible
yep governor yeah yep 100 percent
yeah i don't know if new zealand's
getting obviously he's getting recalled
but i don't know if
he's going to be out of the office
because
by the time that whole process happens
california's me wide open
so being like all right [ __ ] it dude i
don't know caitlyn jenner i listened to
her speak and she was interviewed i
think on
i think i don't know who it was but
hannity yeah
i was i was moderately impressed with
what she had to say i i don't know she
seems she definitely seems like an
old-school
sort of conservative in in
in the in the way that i think
california needs in terms of like you
got to have some push back to this
democratic supermajority
you can't have just an echo chamber
where everybody's big union
and everybody is just on one side of the
equation
but how is it going how the [ __ ] is that
going can we have some pushback and
different ideas i drove down
sunset today because i picked up my car
from the shop
dude when's that saying went downstairs
dude it's a [ __ ] there's so many there's
so many businesses it's shanties it
looks like
i i thought i was in i am legend it's
literally just like dead
there's no signage just everything's
least lisa you go down there
it's so sad well now so newsom
is this new thing he's just going to
give everyone in california money
now that's his that's his latest pledge
which is going to
keep people at home even more it's
insane it's nuts
you know the you know what i keep i
always think i always come back to this
thing which is like
diet and exercise you know you can read
all the diet books you want
you can go on the internet you can be
all by all the snack well
locale whatever but we all know what it
takes right
just no one wants to do it but it's just
diet exercise just diet next says it
society's kind of that way too it's real
basic [ __ ]
and giving people money and
over-regulating all the big grandiose
plans
pie in the sky we're going to give every
kid in school a
computer so they'll know but it never
[ __ ] works
it just doesn't work it's like diet and
exercise like
family education get back to the [ __ ]
basement self-reliance and personally
that's it
that's all we got uh it never everything
else
i wish all the other [ __ ] worked it just
doesn't it doesn't work
it can't work but yeah i
i do think that that recall thing has
scared him
shitless and i think that there there's
a federal notice when they reach
california
there's a lot of company well you know
where we work out at zoo culture that
jim zoo culture
the owner bradley martin he just went
back to court
uh last week because he stayed open to
the entire pandemic
and they kept [ __ ] with them so i
would show up there and we couldn't park
our cars so the city took away parking
okay we would just park across the
street at the park and then walk over so
they would keep [ __ ] when they keep
[ __ ]
they turned off his lights they turn off
his lights turn off the power so they
just keep [ __ ] with them
and then now gyms are open in la and
it's like
what all right so what are you gonna
what do you wanna do and he's like yeah
i'm back in court dude
like they're taking they're trying to
make a like they're trying to make me
the example like this what happens
what happens if you don't government
government yeah just for clarity
turning off the power is [ __ ] up but
turning off the lights can be a courtesy
i mean like if you i didn't mind it you
know the bathroom left it on in the hall
and somebody comes in behind you i agree
it definitely didn't stop us from
lifting i was like that's kind of nice
yeah
it's not that crazy music power off
that's [ __ ] the lights the lights
different story yeah because you look
good better in the shade
yeah jesus what else you got jen scary
how about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this wrote a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son